Stella you are on the Academy you're
such an awesome person thank you making
busy 3000 yeah it's just over 3,000 so
almost 4,000 mmm I guess you're making
three or four thousand pounds a month
yes in property yes so I currently have
four HMOs and one si one service
accommodation for HMOs when did you come
to the crash course and join the Academy
I joined in October so not leavin that
long ago and where did you come to the
crash course I came okay so the
properties that you've got was that
after before joining the Academy so I've
actually got to before absolutely okay
so that story you're from London yeah
what do you do for a living full time
outside of property I'm IT application
that list okay and go from IT to
property a little bit different tell me
the story well so I graduated did the
whole degree master's and then I went
into work and I just hated it I work in
the corporate world so it's longer hours
it's a lot of sucking off it's a lot of
trying to climb that ladder and I just
thought this is just so frustrating yes
so I try to look for something outside
of that try to see what else I could do
and also I just wanted to find someone
that was passionate about not something
that I was working just for the sake of
working yeah yeah so I started to
venture an out of it and just came
across a property and for maybe I'd give
this a try how did you come across
property um so I looked at the different
YouTube videos I've done for research
during poverty grits and I thought let
me actually get starting into this and
see what I can do
yes so it's like a similar patent a lot
of people then watch these videos see
you people now you know people are
watching your videos that probably will
be sat in this chair in six twelve limbs
time you know did you watch
Wednesday videos Wednesday's video
dinner videos yes when you used to watch
women's Wednesday last year did you know
that you were gonna be on as Wednesday I
never would have imagined that come this
far okay so you just you're in a job not
loving it noise the first a lot young
lady you know living life but just not
necessarily living the idea of having to
work 40 hours a week for 40 years no
right I was tired
are you still in 90 I am still I think
it's more now I need to get through that
mindset mmm cuz it's easy to say okay
now I'm financially free I can move but
now I need to get to that mindset of
leaving at 9:00 to 5:00 that traditional
route yes that you go down so I'm still
trying to work on that tomorrow's there
do you think I know you almost there do
you feel like a little bit now you've
got your property income and of course
property comes fantastic but this is
very new to you yes so so it's good that
you're not rushing or going crazy but
you're making between three and four
thousand a month in property with your
fault with your four houses awesome your
IT job income I guess now you don't need
to do that like tomorrow if you got
fired presumably you don't know what
your exclusive will you'll be fine I'll
be fine
you'll be fine so going to work from a
position of choice how does that feel
compared to going from a position of
having to it's perfect it's absolutely
perfect there's a sense of release yeah
an offense of freedom that you have of
knowing that I don't need this job like
I'm not here because I have to be him
here because I want to be here you know
having that choice to say I could easily
put my resignation tomorrow yeah there's
a sense of freedom that comes to having
that choice yes absolutely do you live
on your own your family I live on my own
do the family what my own I have mom
brother and sister yeah I'm back in Kent
yeah tell me what you family make of
your crazy property ventures so at first
when I started day four I was crazy to
go into it people are absolutely nuts
and
it's just one of those things I was like
what never heard of that I can't work
yeah you know but as I started really
getting involved in there and actually
started taking on properties they saw
they saw the change they saw that it was
actually working it was possible and
food that I've actually managed to get
my mum and my aunt on to your that's
that's the dream because a lot of people
that I speak to when they're just
starting out you've been in property now
a good few months and you've got some
results but a lot people say you know my
family really skeptical my family trying
to protect me they don't want me to do
it but then what often happens is
usually it's like you don't do it don't
do it and then you do it and you get
some success that there's a case of will
say you know we'll see and then you
suddenly start getting really successful
and then it's like you've changed you
know and my family just will they ever
support me but the fact that your family
were skeptical but then when they saw
your results there now like boom I'm in
and then join the Academy I know just
coming from their first reaction when I
bought this I do up they are now and
calling me and asked me for advice it's
like wow yeah you're like what in your
20s 28 28 same age as me yes oh it's
always dangerous the same age as me you
know working from a position of choice
yeah
so the four deals that you've got you've
got did they all come I know you joined
the Academy midway when you were midway
through because you just bought two
houses but the the strategies did it all
kind of come from the training from
myself from the crash course and the
videos in the Academy absolutely so your
enthusiasm making the property as a
business has really resonated with me
instead of seeing it as a side business
I'm saying this as my main business so
I'm going out there and I'm talking to
vendors as if this is my business
business so I think having that mind
changes really changed in the way I'm
speaking to people and they're taking me
more seriously and do now come into me
of different office and especially going
to direct landlords there see more okay
this is more business not trying to
scare me or anything
it's what you've done where you've been
going straight to the lungs direct
you've been using the special websites
which is really ok let's talk the deal
okay so you go for one service
accommodation yes do you own that or do
you control it control it so you don't
even know it tell me what taught me
through that so um so that's on they
went to went deal I got that food to
landlord directly it's a one bed in
London doing really well
language was nice and managed to seal
that deal within a week it was literally
just meeting her and had good in that
report yes got me that deal so when did
that go live so that went live actually
last month last month and then the
bookings coming in I can't get that give
me a nice life really well how many how
much since he went live in the last
month how much income or how much
bookings entirely generated so we so for
this month we managed to get I think 50%
for this month
going from March having looked at the
brewery yeah but going for March we're
looking at 80% yeah and 50% so this last
but it's always quite yeah what in terms
of revenue do you know how much doesn't
profit
yeah that's great so that deal literally
you rent it yeah you control it and then
you and then you rewrote it out but you
do it legally yes with all the correct
contracts well home away where the most
the bookings be coming from bookends
okay calm yes okay love that price so
that's your one deal easy-peasy but you
know what there that it sounds easy
peasy you know I just went and did it
you know
but actually there's a lot of systems
and there's a lot of work that does go
into it there is a lot there is a lot
just to try and make sure they can get
it up and running and systemizing thing
that's where I am right now just making
sure I'm puttin things in place what I
heard in the last boot camp I'm not
trying to implement that
yes so that was the academy training yes
the revolution's
amazing so many good little nuggets I
got from that yes you you can have a
batch does people say to me and it kind
of ticks me off because they're like I'm
not gonna kind of know just watch the
YouTube videos and it's like you've got
a subpoena why do why do you say that
because I watched YouTube videos and I
think there's something about being in
that view you get more information out
of it you get your questions answered
directly I mean you're sitting around
people who are in the same place it's
you you want to learn the same thing
this year you can bounce off each other
or bounce off ideas is some amazing
place to network with people as well
yeah and I also think the way I always
look at it I mean even your family yeah
you can send you a family look you're a
funny I want you C to the watch do
YouTube videos go on the fridge but no
get to the kruskal's go on the Academy
because you've done it you're making the
money off of the back of it for me I
always look at it like reading a theory
book and then driving the car you know
the theory is great and you do need it
and most of my kind of members also
watch the YouTube videos and of course
but then you've got to go in the car man
you gotta do you wanna do it you need to
instructor with you so that you can do
well so that right do I say are you
gonna get more like that or is the
thousand pounds a month for you are you
like gonna call it a day or what's the
plan
I'm hoping to get more like that yeah my
hoping to go more to be our stuff huh so
yeah just seeing where things go talk
about the other three then they're all
be are our deals no HMO deals so short
enough yeah okay all that all winter in
HMOs okay so you've got one regiment
service accommodation and then three
rent two HMOs where are they yes so four
in Oxford okay good good okay so talk to
me about the figures and hagel them so
the first one I got that is a lot of
hard work a lot of those got into that
before I got that first one yeah it was
through an agent and I was basically
just knocking on doors and speaking to
people waiting for that yes really and
it was daunting it really was going
through that process but once I got that
yes and it was just amazing yeah
absolutely amazing so there's an
eight-bed Donald's my first one all
ensuite rooms it was beautiful and I
managed to get it rented out within
three weeks and that's good did you say
the serviced accommodation is that
London that's in London in three
hectares or in Oxford
so the HMOs are they all from the same
landlord or they often different they're
from different landlords so free of them
off from the actually family members
okay
so they all invest in properties they're
all family members and it's just
recommendations I always say I don't
know if you would agree with this your
first deal it's always the hardest
absolutely because I but you even said
it once you've got that yes I mean the
confidence that goes up not only the
confidence in you but then the
confidence in the landlords because you
can now say look this is what I'm doing
rather than just oh I'm just kind of
starting out yeah because when you're
speaking to them you always get that I
wash experience yeah so it's just
finding that one person that one
landlord is serrated to believe in you
to get that first how did you finance
these wintermen deals so I actually took
out a loan for the first one yeah to put
in the first three months meant fun so
by using that learn I've actually
managed to recycle that money for the
rest of the mint event oh that's so cool
so when you join the Academy did you
have life savings did you have no money
at all where were you at so I had a bit
of savings from what I'd saved up from
the meant to meant Dill's the profits no
but before so when when when you first
started out in property yeah where were
you at like financially financially I
was okay I'd saved a bit
nothing I'm a major so you probably had
about nine ten thousand say okay so
you've got nine or ten grand yeah cuz a
lot of people ask me this question
Stella and I think you're going to help
a lot people say to me I've got nine run
in the bank I'm going
where do I go from here like what I
would do so you had a little bit of says
but you went on the Academy yes so you
used all of your savings because the you
know is more than 9 grand
yes so you used all of your savings and
probably am some yeah to to get trained
yeah I mean this is a really interesting
topic I mean you're like the perfect
case study right now because it's hard
for me to advise it so is this to me
something I've got ten grand what would
you do for me to say I'll do the Academy
it's a bit like hmm it sounds like I'm
trying to sell to them almost or I'm
trying I'll do the Academy just because
I've run the Academy yeah I don't even
see the money I don't take a salary from
the training company but hang on ha if I
was starting over again and I hang
around I do own the Academy yeah because
the other alternative is to invest it
into a tiny little cheap single a house
up north at best and get 200 quid a
month yeah so you invested everything
into the Academy so now you've like for
all your money answer and you've got
normally and then how did you then get
forward doing deals
it's insane I know honestly since I
joined the Academy it's just been
flowing clove had a different mindset
yeah I mean I've got the first two and
it was great but I was in my comfort
zone still because I was having that
income I'm gonna have my nine-to-five so
I will see in that as a side business
just something to help me along yeah but
since joining the Academy I'm now
starting to think of it as my business
yes and I want to jump from that 20 to
100 right now so I'm moving I'm making
those movements I'm putting in the work
that needs to be put in there to make
sure that I get to where I need to go
yeah okay so first went to medieval oh
how much did you get a loan for it was
funny father thirty thousand twenty
twenty thousand okay sorry and that
twenty thousand did that just get you
warm intimate yeah Wow
so this is like a seriously hefty read
to read okay talking to the things that
how what was the breakdown
so the breakdown was the three months up
front yes as females up front plus the
deposit okay so that was about how much
Simon total mmm what's the rent on that
it's about four thousand eight hundred a
month a month yeah so oh my goodness so
literally three months rent up front
that's like almost 15 grand yeah was it
as well Wow that's pretty much 2012 um
yeah
did you lease the furniture so I managed
to negotiate having the furniture put in
by the landlord right so 21 years needed
for that yeah risk it was a big risk but
obvious Kyle's willing to take cuz I
knew I had to make it work boom sugar
taking out a 20 grand loan okay to
invest into one rent to rent deal three
months upfront rent which is almost
fifteen grand plus the deposit is your
20 grand gone and then you can't rent
you out and you screwed yeah absolutely
because some of your expenses are so
high did you not fear I mean I had a bit
of fear but I had to push that to the
side because I knew that this is
something that I wanted to go in you'd
have done that on a wrong deal you would
be financially screwed absolutely so I
had to make sure that the numbers worked
yes and I made sure that I had the right
train in yeah to go into such a deal
well that goes back to the Academy yeah
exactly
and that's why I would always say
somebody go get training you have to
yeah because if you take out the wrong
if you go for the wrong deal it can
really have a messy constable yes and
people do this sometimes people have a
bash meaning I don't want to pay for the
trains or pay for my mistakes instead
and then get a renter in do and then
they can't rent it yeah and then you
stuffed
so five four thousand eight hundred a
month so that is how many bedrooms no
tomorrow 8 bed and you read it all the
rooms out in three weeks
oh that's just brilliant because did you
do diligence you have to train in you
spell
to the right people you spoke to ought
to hate to marry management company
presumably in the area do you balance it
yourself would you have it managed at a
moment I'm managing it myself
Yeah right imagine yourselves not
problem to begin with you're gonna learn
loads of doing it what you want to make
it more passive streamline it okay so
that makes sense so as a result of that
load you got that rent to rent do did
you did you say that then you just saved
all the profit from the event tonight
yeah so the profit and obviously cause
female self fun I was getting that back
plus top of it profit so I can use it
Mac today invested never deals in more
intamin deals Wow you are amazing
honestly it's so your story it's so cool
hearing that outside of the renter meant
revolution program on the Academy well
there's been your favorite training on
the Academy DfE DfE deal finding
extravaganza yeah yeah yeah infinite
returns
oh you like that one I'd never heard of
that before my life so that was really
good what does infinitely says mean so
it is when I used to be infinitely time
for my property so you buy refurbished
and refinance
yeah sure but you kind of got infinite
returns on your money alone yeah pretty
much you did because you point norm of
your own money put the bank's money
again isn't it nice to get rich off of
the bank yeah the bank in which I love
you so you brought money from the bank
yes and then you vested it and you put
any of your own money in you got
infinite return yeah so that's insane
okay what are your plans for 2020 and
what do you need from me so my plans for
2020 is just to get better connections
yeah finally good deals out there get
better deals start on B ah ah um what I
need from you is just advice let me know
where to go and what to do next
if you have any properties that you want
me to
I'm like do you know what I'm so getting
that question because people I was
runnin across boss and someone said to
me I've tried rent events in Birmingham
and no landlords in Birmingham well past
the anomalies I went to bed and the week
before I had passed four of my HMOs on
to carry members on went to rent no one
not even less interesting because I'm a
Birmingham landlord next week I must and
people sometimes don't think to even ask
the question yeah but the fact that you
just said to me even have you got any
properties that's what you need to do in
business you need to suppose just ask
the question yeah no but I used to us
yeah but I didn't give you a no I'll
give you I'll check yeah you will be
like your winner now on when is
Wednesday your meat Academy so you will
be on my top little black book before
reach out to okay so be are on and so
you making great money from red to red
what are you doing with that cash flow
are you saving it are you yep so at the
moment I'm saving it to try and find
that right vor dill yes it's just
amazing the finance that's a bit
difficult yeah cuz for a br a finland
doesn't know so that's you buy a
property you rethought refurbish it add
value and then you refinance it pull the
money back out which is a great wealth
building strategy because we have been
do reap up until now last few months
very successful in my hat is you've been
operating as a property entrepreneur
because she's been of course you've been
investing money but you've been making
cash flow which is awesome making a few
three four thousand times a month but
now it's how can I take that cash flow
or take other people's money and invest
it into property and also build wealth
and build a portfolio that way so I
think that's a really really a really
smart strategy met of course I'll help
you with that I thank you for a deals
that you and brainstorm and and of
course would you be non-winners
Wednesday we have like special dinners
specifically for winners so you'll be
you'll be by to the next
so that's really exciting tell me what
advice you'd give to your six-month
younger self when you were just watching
me on youtube thinking wow that seems
cool what would you advise yourself
dreams can come true like if you put in
that effort and you keep on striving
towards you what do you want it will
happen yeah it will happen it's not just
a dream it's not just for the one person
so powerful okay
well listen we need to do a plot to
interview some point you've killed it on
the rental rent side I'm sure in another
six months years time we're gonna hear
how you've done development and some
crazy stuff there specifically the
renter inside what would be your top tip
to finding good deals so I would say
just make sure it's in the right area
make sure your numbers are correct don't
go into a deal just because it doesn't
know what the table make sure it is a
good deal and a lot of people will throw
bad doors at you and you probably be
tempted to sign it because you know you
want that first door but actually hold
back make sure it's correct I just take
that time to consider it did you have to
walk away from any deals I have no I
want to say no Jim you know so what
would you say to someone that was
thinking of coming to crash course do it
do it the people that you meet on the
crash course are absolutely
people have networked with adviced I've
got some people friendly they're willing
to help you well I'm good just do it I'm
gonna leave in this video a link to the
crash course so anyone who's listening
get yourself booked on below you heard
it from me you heard it from Stella and
thank you so much for coming in man
thank well chat we'll have dinner yes 20
level